That's a very important question because
you have to learn to love whatever you
do like in the failures as much as the
successes because they'll probably be a
lot more failures than successes.
And so that's a very important lesson to
learn early on.
And I learned it early in my career
because my phd really got off to a
pretty poor star and so there's a long
period of time where I had to say,
is this worth it?
And uh,
many of my friends were just sort of
saying like,
you know,
you're already accepted into medical
school,
why do you even need this?
And I think I was just really like the,
the puzzle that I was sort of trying to
figure out what is a compelling enough
to me that I kept going with it.
So I think in science you have to be
very patient and you have to enjoy like
the process and it's nice to think about
where the process will take you.
But it's important to enjoy like each
aspect of the process itself.
Um,
and so I think that we're lucky because
we're in a time right now that there are
so many tools available that there are
many discoveries being made,
so um,
you know,
there's just many opportunities to
advance the field and it's coming from
all directions,
so that's a lucky time,
but obviously there will be droughts
where we figured we've kind of tapped
the genome to its full potential and
looking for the next thing and the
difficulties with each aspect of
changing paradigms.
So they'll,
there will be periods have already
experienced some,
maybe not like the biggest I could
experience,
but it definitely experienced long
periods of failed work.
Um,
and I just,
I still enjoy it.
I just enjoy the day to day and that's
important to do,
like teaching.
I love teaching.
Yeah,
love.
That's one of the reasons why I didn't
look at.
I looked at being in an undergraduate
campus because I really enjoy teaching.
I think it's,
I think it's wonderful and you're very
lucky to be with such.
I mean all students are really exciting,
but it's really lucky to be with such
motivated students.
It's,
you know,
it's an easy job,
so it's,
it's really up to you.
Um,
you know,
if the students are engaged,
it's something you have to think about.
How do you engage them.